at the line don't allow the easy setup
to let them get that confidence and get
the setup that they want's got it
to Matthews and elander off the
post first good look on this third power
play now martyr in front BS scor H number
Mitch Mar went to get the puck and Austin
Matthews celebrates a milestone to get
the leads even yeah 300 in 482 games and
this one starts with neander right in the
slot with a quick release and off the post
and sometimes that just gets the defense a
little bit settled back you can see the setup
was there just throw to the net it hits off
John Taris in front and right on the door
step is Matthews a reach back but look at
where he shoots that puck from from his back
foot doesn't waste any time getting that one
there and not allowing Allen to get over
and get set up gets it into that top corner